Announcer: From the nation's capital, the
American Enterprise Institute for Public Policy
Research presents Public Policy Forums, a
series of programs featuring the nation's
top authorities presenting their differing
views on the vital issues which confront us.
Today's topic, Weapons Against Inflation.
Unless you're a visitor just in from outer
space or perhaps you've been living on a desert
island somewhere, you've noticed that the
cost of living has gone up tremendously over
the last several months to the point where
today it costs twice as much to buy goods
and services as it did to buy the same things
just 12 years ago.
President Carter's voluntary anti-inflation
program is aimed at cooling the inflationary
fires, but will it work?
What are the alternatives?
How great is the possibility of a recession
sometime during 1979?
If it comes, how serious will it be?
Is the President likely to ask for and perhaps
receive permission from Congress perhaps even
stand by permission to invoke mandatory wage
and price controls in the near future?
And what was our experience the last time
the country had mandatory economic controls?
Some of the country's biggest companies have
promised to go along with the Carter anti-inflation
program.
But what about labor, especially with major
contract negotiations in the works during
1979?
Welcome to another Public Policy Forum presented
by AEI, the American Enterprise Institute,
a nonprofit, nonpartisan research and education
organization.
This roundtable discussion will explore the
topic, Weapons Against Inflation.
Appearing on our panel today are Alfred E.
Kahn, Chairman of the Council on Wage and
Price Stability.
Dr. Kahn, with a PhD in economics from Yale
University, is counselor to the President
for inflation, Mr. Carter's chief inflation
fighter.
Before taking over as the man in charge of
the voluntary wage and price control program,
Dr. Kahn headed the Civil Aeronautics Board,
where he helped bring about airline deregulation.
Alan Greenspan, former chairman of the President's
Council of Economic Advisers under President
Gerald Ford.
Dr. Greenspan's PhD in economics is from New
York University.
He is presently president of an economics
consulting firm, Townsend Greenspan, in New
York City.
Dr. Greenspan has held numerous government
positions, including the chairmanship of four
White House economic committees.
Rudolph A. Oswald is director of research
for the National Labor Organization, the AFL-CIO.
He's a former Fulbright scholar who holds
a PhD also in economics from Georgetown University.
Dr. Oswald has devoted much of his professional
career researching the effect of the nation's
economy on the well-being of American workers.
Marvin Kosters is a resident scholar at AEI
and director of its Center for the Study of
Government Regulation.
He too holds a PhD in economics from the University
of Chicago.
Dr. Kosters has served as senior staff economist
to the President's Council of Economic Advisers
and as Deputy Assistant to the President for
Economic Affairs during the Ford administration.
He spent three years as Associate Director
of the President's Cost of Living Council.
John Charles Daly will moderate today's roundtable
discussion.
Mr. Daly is a former news correspondent and
commentator for CBS News and ABC News.
He is a former ABC network Vice President
and once headed the Voice of America.
Now, here is Mr. Daly.
John: This Public Policy Forum, part of a
series presented by the American Enterprise
Institute is concerned with what may well
be called the enigma of free society's inflation.
For nearly a decade and a half, we have been
struggling with an inflationary economy at
home while keeping a wary eye on the often
dramatic struggles with inflation by our colleagues
in the industrial and developing societies
abroad.
There's the sense that as with the common
cold, we're not sure where inflation came
from or what we should or can do about it.
At the beginning of 1978, the administration
initiated a voluntary program under which
government, business, and labor would cooperate
in an anti-inflation program inspired by persuasion
and publicity.
The results have been less than inspiring.
At the end of 1978, the administration issued
an urgent call to battle.
The President outlined a new plan of attack
which in his words will cut the budget deficit,
slash federal hiring, and reduce the federal
workforce, restraint federal pay, delay further
tax cuts, remove needless regulations, use
federal policy to encourage more competition,
set specific standards for both wages and
prices throughout the economy generally limiting
wage increases to 7% and price increases to
five and three quarters percent.
And the President concluded, "We will use
all the powers at our disposal to make this
program work," announcing that legislative
proposals to implement elements of the program
would go to the Congress.
In January, the President highlighted his
surprise weapon, a real wage insurance proposal
as an additional incentive for labor cooperation.
Workers who observed the wage standards in
the program would be eligible for a tax rebate
if the inflation rate is more than 7%.
These then as of now and if the Congress approves
new legislation are the principal weapons
in our arsenal against inflation.
Dr. Kahn, the President said in a press conference
recently, "Obviously, with more than 1,000
different kinds of decisions to be made, there
will be some flexibility."
Do you and the president anticipate any major
modifications now that you've heard from many
constituencies during the legally mandated
public comment period just concluded?
Dr. Kahn: I don't think one could characterize
the kinds of modifications that we're thinking
about as major.
But there are two kinds that we are very intensively
considering.
The first is in response to an almost unanimous
criticism by business as well as labor that
our treatment of fringe benefits and in particular
the catch-up costs of maintaining existing
levels of benefits is simply too stringent.
And therefore, we are contemplating a number
of possible ways of introducing a modicum
of flexibility and treating them.
The second is in response to the obvious point
that's been made by labor, but it was made
by me in testimony back in 1971 that a standard
that permits the pass on of uncontrollable
costs with a fixed percentage margin permits
accumulation of profits on the basis of additional
costs, and we're trying to devise ways of
preventing the earning of additional profits
on additional costs.
John: All right.
Dr. Greenspan, what are the similarities and
differences between President Carter's new
program and President Ford's win program?
Dr. Greenspan: Well, if I can expand President
Ford's win program into two parts, one, a
call for severe restriction on fiscal policy,
federal spending, and on the budget deficit,
and the other, something of a vague freeze.
I would say there is quite a good deal similar
with the same problems.
In my view, all that is desirable and, in
fact, all that is necessary to restrain inflation
is in the first part of both of those programs
that is the restraint on federal government
expenditure and indirectly on its credit creating
capacities.
The second part, namely, the guidelines, I
think are counterproductive.
Actually are not part of an anti-inflation
program, but in my view, actually, ultimately
add to inflation.
So I would suspect that the guideline part
was wholly inappropriate response to inflation
under the name win and I would suspect that
would come out pretty much the same with that
part of President Carter's program.
They're both losers.
John: All right.
Dr. Oswald, will you...we've already had reference
to it.
Will you summarize organized labor's objections
toward the administration program?
Dr. Oswald: Organized labor's objections are
that it's described as a voluntary program,
but it really is mandatory in terms of wages,
because there is an enforcement mechanism
there, which is every employer is willing
to enforce a set guideline of 7%.
Contrary to what you said in your introduction,
there is not a five and three quarter percent
guideline on prices.
As a matter of fact, the only mention of a
price guideline is nine and a half percent.
And it talks about a half of percent deceleration
from sort of price increases that took place
in 1976, 1977.
And that says those who raise prices the most
can do so again, and those who are most responsible
at that time can do less now.
That hardly seems like an equitable program
because it means that there is not really
a mechanism for controlling prices because
there is no manpower to do it and the consumer
doesn't know what an appropriate price increase
is and no other source of income is controlled
except wages.
That's the basic objection.
And therefore, the labor movement said, "If
there are to be controls, let's make them
by legislation, effectively enforce against
everybody so that they apply effectively against
all segments of the economy, not just against
workers who are working for wages."
John: All right.
Dr. Kosters, you have served with the Council
of Economic Advisors as Associate Director
of the Cost of Living Council and authored
Controls and Inflation, the economic stabilization
program in retrospect, so you have been in
this battlefield for a long time.
Do you think the President's voluntary program
would work?
Dr. Kosters: Well, I think that there are
two ways of addressing that question.
The first way would be to ask, is it likely
to break down?
And by breaking down, I mean, will there happen
to be a wage increase or possibly even a price
increase somewhere that seems so much out
of line, what are set out as the standards
that the whole program gets discredited?
Now, that's the tendency under any program.
The program that I was involved in, we said
those were the last cows in the barn.
But one can do that only about so long and
it wears a little bit thin.
So that's always a risk and there are good
reasons for it.
The second way to address the question is
to ask, is the rate of inflation likely to
be lower after it's all over with than it
was before?
Well, by virtue of the standards themselves,
I would say that's quite unlikely.
We have a great deal of experience with that
both in Europe and in the United States.
All of that experience that I'm aware of is
negative and I see no reason why we're likely
to fare any better under this one.
John: All right.
But now let's come to grip with the weapons
against inflation.
Dr. Herbert Stein whom you all know has had
a great deal of experience with inflation
and its problems, has written of the last
decade of our struggles with inflation.
"Two lessons of this recent history are relevant
today.
One, do not think we can flirt with controls
and not get them, and two, do not think that
the ineffectiveness of controls which has
roots deep in the American economic and political
system can be overcome by sufficiently enthusiastic
operators."
[inaudible 00:13:12].
Would you respond, Dr. Kahn?
Dr. Kahn: Well, it's a little difficult to
know where to begin.
The notion that any kind of controls or incomes
policy can only do harm, it seems to me can
only spring from an assumption that the level
at which let's say the Teamsters sign for
wage increase is somehow God-given or competitive
market determined in the same way as let's
say the free price of natural gas if it were
uncontrolled.
I submit that there's an enormous difference
between those two.
If you hold the price of natural gas below
its marginal cost, you're gonna get shortages.
Is there anybody on this panel who believes
that if you can induce the Teamsters by one
device or another to reduce their wage settlement
from 11% to 10% to 9% to 8% to 7%, that you're
gonna have a shortage of Teamsters that this
is a competitive market, which by University
of Chicago-God-given standards should not
be interfered with.
I submit that's an absurdity.
Now, I'm not suggesting that these weapons
are total.
And I'm not, as you know, an enthusiastic
supporter of the guidelines.
I have been quoted correctly as referring
to them as those stinking wage price guidelines.
I don't love them.
But on the other hand, I do not believe it
is logical to speak of a lot of these prices
and wages as though they are determined in
a competitive market so in such a way that
to interfere will produce enormous distortions
in the economy.
I won't go on a great length.
There's a lot of differences from the win
program which alone attracted me to this.
One difference is that we don't have any ties
yet which have win on them.
John: I merely suggest you wait.
Dr. Kahn: Exactly.
The notion that all the European experience
is negative is, I submit, a piece of folklore.
The British experience does suggest that it
is possible by having some sort of incomes
policy if you have a sufficient acceptance
of the notion that we are in a process of
mutual frustration, if that becomes sufficiently
widespread that you can, in fact, at least
for periods of time, induce certain restraints.
It is not an accident that every Western democratic
capitalist country has attempted in one way
or the other the growth for incomes policy.
Conclusion, I'm not at all suggesting that
this is the part of the program that turns
me on.
I'm not suggesting that it will do any good
in the absence of monetary and fiscal restraints.
And I wish you would all mention the fact
that we have a very comprehensive intention
at least to attack structural defects in the
economy and government interventions that
inflate costs and prevent competition.
Dr. Oswald: But I think what you've really
described as the controls program, which you
have attempted to put into effect on the wage
side, without any legal basis for putting
it into effect, which in a sense denies the
appropriate procedure by which issues can
be handled.
There should be an appropriate body which
has sufficient manpower to hear cases.
There should be a legal basis for punishing
those that don't adhere rather than by some
vague threats, which don't really have a legal
basis where you attempt to use laws not for
the purpose for which they were designed but
for other purposes.
And if the inflation is really as bad as it
is, if we're going to have these sorts of
things, then let's do it right.
Let's do it by law.
Let's do it equitably.
John: Dr. Oswald, would you elucidate what
you mean by using laws in way other than they
are intended to be used?
Dr. Oswald: Well, the President indicated
that in order to enforce these guidelines,
I believe that's the words that he used, he
was going to use government procurement actions.
He was going to use the actions of the Export-Import
Bank.
And since then, he's made allusions to other
laws as a basis for trying to make sure that
there is compliance.
Those laws all were established with specific
goals in terms of providing for government
procurement, for providing...for aiding American
exports abroad, a number of other things.
If we're going to have a program that is geared
towards inflation, why not set up a law that
deals with that directly rather than through
this indirect fashion?
John: Dr. Kahn, would you like to respond?
Dr. Kahn: Well, I'll be very brief.
When a lawyer tells me that I'm not following
due process, I tend to hold on to my wallet.
When an economist tells me the same thing,
I'm gonna hold on to my checkbook as well.
I'm not an expert on the law.
Our lawyers tell us that it is perfectly reasonable
for the government to use its regulatory authority
to refuse, for example, to pass on inordinate
wage or cost increases.
And I'm not a lawyer so I guess take it up
with my priest.
John: Dr. Greenspan:
Dr. Kahn: Chaplain was the word I was groping
for.
Dr. Greenspan: I presumably you were not referring
to me in that.
Dr. Kahn: No, I'd never make that mistake.
Dr. Greenspan: I'd like to go back to some
very important and really fundamental questions,
which Dr. Kahn raised right in the beginning.
I think that we will get back to Dr. Oswald's
issue because that's gonna proliferate this
discussion extensively.
I agree, the Teamsters do not strike me as
a union characterized by extreme competition.
I would not therefore...
Dr. Oswald: I wish I could be that diplomatic.
Dr. Greenspan: I would not therefore conclude
that the solution to the problem is guidelines.
I think that there are obviously far more
effective and long run solutions to that problem
such as deregulating the truckers which working
through the market mechanism, I think do have
surprising impact on the Teamsters themselves.
The question as to whether or not the European
experience is valid or not is extremely difficult
one.
I tend to conclude pretty much the way Dr.
Kosters comes out.
But I will grant you that it is extraordinarily
difficult to read some of that evidence.
I would say the hypothesis that stipulates
that they work is extremely difficult to demonstrate,
and I personally believe impossible, although
I will grant you the opposite is also rather
difficult.
The reason I believe that democratic societies
grope for this type of mechanism when confronted
with inflation is that it perceives this sort
of approach as creating some form of short
term political benefit.
And in certain instances, it does.
I don't deny, for example, that President
Nixon's freeze in August of 1971 did, in fact,
stop the rate of inflation.
But the problem that we have is that while
there was this pressure for short term benefits,
there was a growing unawareness of the longer
term costs that such policies invariably generate.
And one of our difficulties that we had in
a societies like ours is that politicians,
the political system as a whole, tends to
over-emphasize short term benefits in virtually
all of its actions without fully comprehending
the long term costs.
And I believe that one of the major problems
that guidelines, controls, mandatory, or non-mandatory
create is they give the illusion of success.
And they do, in fact, create problems far
greater than I think we conceivably imagine.
We've had many problems in this area.
One of the more recent examples is the difficulties
that the legacy of the Nixon control program
has created for us, namely, the problem in
oil and energy price controls and the difficulties
that have emerged in unleaded gasoline and
in a number of other areas.
I submit that what we tend to create are huge
bureaucratic systems which essentially shuffle
paper and cannot very easily be demonstrated
to have significant impacts on the overall
price or wage level.
Overall, I would tend to argue that in the
longer run, because they thwart productivity,
because they generate imbalances in the system,
they tend over the long run to be pro-inflation
rather than anti-inflation.
John: Dr. Kosters, you wanna taka a shot too?
Dr. Kosters: Yeah.
Well, I think it's important to recognize
that whenever you have a set of standards,
whether voluntary or mandatory, the one piece
of policy in the context of all of the policies
that are going on.
This, of course, is what makes it difficult
to assess the impact of any given program
at any time.
Take, for example, the British case.
It is true that inflation came down while
the policy was enforced.
But it's also true that there was a good deal
of belt-tightening going on when the policy
was implemented.
And I think that the fact that other policies
are being made at the same time and that they're
being made in the context of the fact that
there is a program of standards creates one
of the main dangers of such a program.
Back when the 1971-72 and so on controls were
enforced, it was often said that the controls
helped to make it possible to have a more
vigorous expansion than we could otherwise
have.
At the present time, it's often said that
we need to make a choice between voluntary
controls, if they are not successful, perhaps
between mandatory controls and recession.
And it seems to me that when one is talking
about that kind of choice, one is talking
about perhaps stimulating the economy somewhat
more than would otherwise be considered prudent.
And that seems like a formula for more inflation
rather than less inflation from everything
we know.
Dr. Kahn: Could I just respond very briefly
to that?
I think this is very useful at narrowing the
controversy between us in some cases to a
point where there is no controversy.
There's no question that when the mandatory
controls were imposed in August of 1971 in
anticipation of an election 15 months ahead
and of course, I'm not impugning the motives
of the Republicans any more than the Democrats
that would have done the same thing if they
were in power.
John: Nor suggesting that history will repeat
itself.
Dr. Kahn: Precisely.
Precisely.
You've taken the words exactly out of my mouth.
The imposition of controls at that time was
obviously part of a deliberate attempt to
inflate the economy and for obvious reasons.
We were making unsatisfactory progress in
reducing unemployment.
And it was thought that if you could impose
the controls, then you could have massive
monetary expansion and budgetary looseness.
And the one was an attempt to make it possible
to do the other.
But we are talking now about a context in
which limitations are being imposed.
Macro-restraint is being followed, and it
is simply an unwillingness on the part of
the government and I think the country to
rely exclusively on a jamming out of the monetary
and fiscal breaks.
The distortions, it seems to me, are far less
likely to be serious than they were in the
context of '71 to '73, though I do not look
forward to a permanent continuation of controls
with any more enthusiasm than you do Mr. Greenspan.
John: Doctor.
Dr. Greenspan: Whether or not we turn out
to be in difficulty a year from now will depend
largely on what happens to monetary and fiscal
policy in the meantime just as it did then.
Man: Well, I think it's important to look
at the change and the situation.
At that time, we had an inflation rate of
a little bit over 4%.
Now, the inflation rate is over nine and a
half percent.
At that time, food prices were relatively
stable.
Food prices now are going up at a twelve and
a half percent rate and they are a major factor
in what consumers buy.
The interest rates have been going up substantially,
which has been pushing up the housing sectors
substantially and the cost of housing.
Medical care then was going up rapidly, is
still going up rapidly.
And energy costs at that time were not yet
shot off by the OPEC situation and are going
up rapidly now and are expected to go up rapidly
in the next few years unless there is some
sort of an intervention.
And monetary and fiscal policy will not address
the problems of food price increases, will
not address directly the sectorial problems
that exist.
And I think to just say that there is some
sort of cosmetic here in terms of wage price
guidelines plus the strong monetary and fiscal
program is going to take care of our inflation
really doesn't look at some of the pressures
in different segments of the economy which
are pushing up the price level much more rapidly.
Man: You know, what basically concerns me
is that his program will beget yours.
And the reason I say that is that I think
it's unrealistic to presume that you can have
a stable equilibrium type guidelines program.
This is not a stable program.
And if it increases, what will start to occur
is we'll begin to find that any even skillfully
crafted program of guidelines or standards
must have necessity, be comprehensible in
a political sense, which means it can scarcely
pick up more than at best 95% of all of the
possible types of wage and price decisions
that wouldn't be made, which is terrific,
except that there are 100 million of them
out there, which means you're dealing with
5 million decisions as an example, which go
outside the guidelines.
As you start to try to bring them in, you
begin to get an extraordinarily burgeoning
system, which ultimately, I fear, is going
to be sanctioned by the Congress as a mandatory
system because it will have all of the characteristics
except the authorizing legislation.
Man: On the question of the rises in energy
prices and food prices, I would agree with
this side of the table, which is, well, from
your point of view on the right, totally,
that the solution for rising energy prices
is not mandatory price control.
The solution for the rising price of beef
is not mandatory price controls or any kind
of price controls, and I think therefore,
to the extent that you really are getting
into a situation in which you're not influencing
what is a real margin of administrative discretion.
But you really are trying to set price below
some sort of equilibrium point.
You are simply concealing from consumers what
the real marginal cost of those supplies is
to the economy.
And I do think that way lies disaster.
The part of the program, however, that I find
terribly attractive is, and again, I recognize
the difference between promise and performance
that we are attempting systematically to look
at these particular sectors, which have been
responsible for the preponderance portion
of the increase in the cost of living and
to try to identify the restrictions on competition,
the insanities of methods of organizations,
such as the insane method that we have for
paying for medical care, the interferences
with the free markets, such as we have, as
part of our agricultural policy or our regulation
on trucking, which, until recently, required
that you take your truck into a food store
full and take them back empty.
I mean, in each of these areas, if you look
at building codes and land use restrictions
and inadequate taxes on land that's held out
of use, there are millions of things that
can be done in these areas.
But the thing that I think should not...and
I would suggest that the people on my left
would probably approve of those attacks but
I suggest that the attempt to substitute total
controls to hold down the price of oil when
the incremental cost of the US economy is
$14 a barrel is in the long run just a disaster.
Man: It seems to me that you could probably
make a case for saying that with a 7% wage
guideline, there'll be a lot of business firms
that do have an incentive to try to enforce
that.
On the other hand, with a voluntary price
guideline, like there's, which is a big price
index, it's an enormously complicated thing
to audit or even to compute.
It'd be difficult to determine just how much
compliance there is.
So in that context, it seems to me that if
one feared the possibility that the wage guidelines
will bite more than the price guidelines that
you would very much favor a reduction in the
increases in the demand that we've been having
in order to avoid the prospect that wages
will tend to be held down and prices will
tend to float upward with a fairly buoyant
demand.
John: Doctor.
Man: But reduction and aggregate demand is
not an assurance that we'll have reductions
in prices.
Our concern is that what we really will have
is a compounding of the problem.
We'll have a continuation of very high inflation.
At the same time, that we will be pushed towards...what
is it, a banana?
And that the pressure towards pushing the
economy towards a recession as a result of
the tight monetary and fiscal policies will
be severe so that we may have the recession
as well as inflation at the same time.
John: Because our time is limited, come to
grip...I ask you to come to grips with some
of the specifics of the program as it's been
announced.
Let's go to real wage insurance, Dr. Kahn.
Dr. Kahn: I find the real wage insurance plan
a very attractive and imaginative one.
John: Would you outline it for the television
viewers?
Dr. Kahn: Yes.
The general notion is that workers who will
settle for wage increases within the 7% standard,
in a sense making an act of faith that they
will not suffer in consequence from a failure
of others to follow will be insulated against
an increase in the cost of living beyond 7%
by having a tax rebate for the difference
between the 7% at which they settle and whatever
the cost of living increase is.
It's a variant on the tax incentive plans
which try to build in to the tax system a
certain incentive to behave in a socially
responsible way in an area which is not subject
to perfect competition.
Man: That presupposes that the reporting that
will be made by the extraordinary numbers
of millions of reports will be accurate.
I think we know in advance the way the system
works, that it will be biased and biased in
a very specific way so that it's quite conceivable
to me that you can have the Bureau of Labor
Statistics report an 8% or 9% wage increase
and have everybody reporting that they complied
under 7%.
That is not something which I find utterly
shocking.
Dr. Kahn: I can't really assess that.
Perhaps you have some basis.
Man: No, our experience with that type of
reporting when there is a reason to report
in certain manner, very significantly balances
the numbers.
Man: All right.
I was gonna say, first of all, that it's superficially
looks like a very attractive plan.
It has a very nice ring to it.
I think the more you look at it in detail,
the worst it looks at least so it seems to
me.
One reason for that is that you have a wide
variety of sizes, the wage increases that
occur every year.
Take, for example, in 1977, first year wage
increases of major unions averaged about 8%,
but about 30% of the people getting increases
under those agreements got increases of less
than 7%.
About 20% got increases of more than 9% so
that about 30% under such a scheme might well
get some real wage insurance.
For a large number of other people who got
wage increases, they wouldn't really have
any interest in this program that just allows
them to keep up with inflation when they could
probably do better in their own bargaining.
So I think that it has a very haphazard kind
of distributional consequence in that regard.
What also makes it I think extremely difficult
is the kind of information that you would
need to have reported if you are going to
pursue such a scheme.
And all the complexities would have to be
spelled out in sufficient detail so that every
IRS auditor would be able to take a look at
the situation like they do individual income
tax returns now.
Man: Well, I will be only brief because I
will shortly exhaust my mind of information
on the subject.
The Treasury experts assure us that there's
no significant difficulty in that kind of
reporting.
On new contracts, it would be necessary to
have some sort of a certification by the commission
on Wage and Price Stability.
But I had understood that you, for years,
were in the business of certifying whether
a settlement did or did not fall within certain
guidelines.
I'm not making a debating point.
I'm may be exaggerating.
Man: That's why I'm very surprised that [crosstalk
00:36:11]
Man: ...consequence of what's happening now.
Yeah, I just wanna make that last point.
Man: I think the Treasury is over-simplifying.
What they're basically saying is that you
take an average earning's figure.
The difficulty is that you have a mix problem,
difficulties of knowing whether you're looking
at a promotion or whether you're looking at
a wage increase.
You have a problem of part time workers.
You have a problem of bonus workers.
I may be the only private employer on this
panel.
And I would be very hesitant to sign that
W-2 form because I'm not terribly certain
whether the raises I get are in fact a wage
increase, a promotion, or what.
And that's true of most or a very substantial
part of small business and a very substantial
part of non-union labor.
I think it's a tremendously complex program,
which we're only seeing the tip of an iceberg.
I suspect the complexities of this issue are
going to baffle us.
John: I think, for the layman, there is one
question which all four of you could help
us with.
We are not necessarily very understanding
of highly technical terms, but we have certain...in
recent times, particularly heard so much about
monetary policy as a principal and most effective
weapon against inflation.
Is there agreement that it should have greater
weight than other programs or is it just equal
to fiscal policy?
Dr. Greenspan.
Dr. Greenspan: I think what we know is that
when you have excessive monetary growth, you
invariably have inflation and vice versa.
And so that I would say, yes, money supply
is very critical.
But I would not merely focus on it as something
you can turn on and off because it, too, is
very critically determined by other things.
In my view, before you can get a grip on money
supply growth and hence on inflation, you've
got to reduce the aggregate credit requirements
in the economy, meaning you've got to reduce
the federal borrowing requirements, which
comes from the budget deficit, from off budget
financing.
You've got to reduce the credit requirements
which the federal government indirectly requires
of the private sector by mandating certain
regulations on safety and environment which
they must borrow against to meet.
I think the federal government in many of
its grants and aid program induces state and
local governments to borrow.
Finally, I think the most important thing
at this particular stage is the tremendous
expansion in the mortgage market, which has
occurred in large part as a consequence of
government subsidy direct and indirect.
And that is what's creating a money supply
problem at this particular point.
And unless we can come to grips with that
particular problem, I do not envisage the
Federal Reserve being capable of restraining
the growth of money supply to non-inflationary
dimensions without creating an explosive increase
in interest rates.
John: Dr. Oswald.
Dr. Oswald: I think I just wanted to amplify
a little bit what you've said, Alan, because
I think some of the money is now being used
for corporate mergers.
It's being used for the expansion of maybe
some of the new gambling activities in New
Jersey and other places.
Things up in that sense are not the new production
that leads to things and it may be more of
shifting around of money than demand for goods
and services.
And I'm not sure that the traditional Federal
Reserve Board actions get at some of the credit
creation that is taking place through new
means of creating credit through the stock
markets, options markets, through futures
markets, through all sorts of new means of
creating credit.
And I'm not sure that we're really addressing
that outside of just raising interest rates
that I think is fairly harmful for a number
of people within the economy.
John: I would like to suggest, gentlemen,
we have put down a very broad base on the
administration's program and the entire subject
and it's time for us to move to the question
and answer session.
In the past 30 years, this country has gone
through six recessions.
What steps is Congress likely to take to prevent
another one?
Will federal budget cuts do the trick?
At what point will we risk a recession?
Aside from mandatory wage and price controls,
what should Congress and the President be
planning for such an emergency?
Now, to challenge our panel members, let's
get the views of the experts in our audience.
All right.
May I have the first question please?
Larry: Larry Rosenberg, National Science Foundation.
The question is addressed to the panel at
large but perhaps first to Professor Kahn.
Many of the suggested solutions to inflation
are of a longer term structural nature, particularly
seemingly the suggestions to make markets
more efficient and more competitive.
Within that realm, do you see any possibilities
for shorter range targets?
Dr. Kahn: Well, the targets will be very short
range.
I expect within the course of the year that
there will be definite movements in the direction
of the deregulation of trucking, for example,
the more thorough deregulation of the railroads.
There will be active discussions of the extent
to which we can have more competition in the
maritime shipping field rather than move toward
tighter and tighter cartelization.
The area of agricultural, restrictions on
output, now don't expect the Millennium.
But certainly, one can move in the direction
always of the less restrictive approach toward
maintaining farm income trade restrictions.
After all, the president just vetoed that
cotton textiles protective legislation.
He vetoed the beef quarter bill that would
have tied his hands more.
Perhaps that gives you enough.
I mean, we're interested in the state regulation
of insurance.
I mean, do you know, for example, that in
the states in which you have open filing that
is more possibility of price competition that
you have markedly lower insurance rates for
liability and property insurance than you
have in another states?
It's kind of a general attitude toward every
way in which the government subsidizes and
protects and limits competition.
And I expect it to produce some results.
John: Yes, doctor.
Man: I don't see that this is really a change
from what government has tried to do always
in terms of trying to affect the economy and
in terms of results, so I don't anticipate
that there will be results in the next 12
months from these types of programs.
Man: Well, look, I don't promise miracles,
but we had an airline regulation system for
40 years, and we changed it this year.
Maybe people will learn that it's not so horrible
after all.
We can make more money.
We can bring bargains to travelers.
We can even have a 3% reduction in price at
the time when the CPI went up 7%.
Man: I think that's a terribly important example.
John: All right.
Next question please.
Yes, Sir.
John: I'm John Kendrick of George Washington
University.
And my question is primarily for Rudy Oswald.
In view of the preponderance of labor costs
and price, do you think it's possible to wind
down inflation without reducing the rate of
increase in wage rates or average hourly compensation?
And if you agree with that, let me ask you,
how would you recommend that we gradually
decelerate the rate of increase in wage rates
in the economy?
Dr. Oswald: Kendrick, I think that you've
written many books on the impact of productivity
in the economy and the ability to have real
gains in the economy as a result of productivity.
Well, part of the gains of productivity can
be used to slow down productivity.
When I spoke before in terms of Dr. Kahn's
notion of looking at sectorial problems, I
think that there are certain sectorial problems
that can be addressed that are not directly
wage related.
And in general, wage changes in the last year,
last three years have not been particularly
pressing in terms of pushing prices up.
There have been substantial attempts to catch
up.
But that's an attempt to say that when somebody
works, he expects to be able to have the ability
to purchase something with what he works for
rather than just paper.
Man: Can I just say one word about that?
I have no intention of putting...ascribing
blame particularly to one part of the economy
or another.
But you really have missed the basic arithmetic
point that Dr. Kendrick made that if 70% of
your sales prices or of your gross national
product goes to labor, then there's absolutely
no way in the world in which you can have
wage increases of 10%, 11%, 9%, or even 7%
a year when we have never come remotely close
on any long range basis to producing productivity
increases of more than 3 and now we're nearly
at the 2% level without getting something
like giving those different examples, 6%,
7%, 8% of inflation per year.
And that's the simple answer to his question.
There is no way.
And I guess that's a matter of simple arithmetic.
The other point I wanted to make was catch
up.
You will always find at least 50% of the population
who have not done as well in the preceding
years the other 50%.
Actually, if you know, the way these frequency
distributions are spread, it's more than 50%
that do less than average.
If you always, always say anybody who is falling
behind has a right to catch up, then you have
built in a permanent engine of inflation.
Catch-up equals inflation.
John: Dr. Kosters.
Dr. Kosters: I certainly agree with the point
on arithmetic that is there is no way in which
you can get inflation to slow down without
having commensurate slowdown in the rate of
wage increase.
But as I understand this program, something
more is intended.
And that is, if I understood kind of correctly
earlier, what he's saying is that the program
plans to look at situations where competition
in the labor market is less prevalent.
Now, it seems to me that that makes sense
if you can induce the institutional change
that makes the situation more competitive
but to use wage controls or a wage standard
or some kind of wage price policy to get a
result that you would not get with the conditions
of competition in that industry, in that sector,
I think is likely to fail.
Man: I think this is so important that I...forgive
me for another second.
John: Please do.
Man: We're asking where are the signs of excessive
aggregate demand, too much spending in the
economy that is pushing wages up?
And we see very little signs of that in most
parts of the economy.
You may say there's excessive spending for
housing and yet construction wages have risen
much less than the average.
And my answer is that the basic problem of
inflation is a social problem.
It is a mark of a society in which people
are constantly increasing their income claims,
both in the wages they demand, in the profit
margin that they add to their wage cost, in
the demands that they place on government
for tax preferences or subsidies.
In the demands for government spending programs,
they all add up to more than we can supply
at constant prices.
And that's what we've been witnessing.
It's justified by some on the grounds of catch
up.
It's justified by others on the ground that
they're in industries which are above average
and productivity.
What we see than is a problem that seems to
us is not easily solvable simply by putting
mark aggregate restraints because that will
cause great unemployment.
It's simple enough to throw 20 million people
out of work, and then they will moderate their
wage demands.
We have to do something by way of inducing
a general spirit of social discipline which
alone can come in my judgment only by a recognition
that we're all like hamsters in a cage running
as fast as we can and staying in the same
place.
I think there's a general recognition that
we've all gotta moderate in some way.
And I don't know how to do that by simply
imposing monetary and fiscal restraints without
serious unemployment.
Dr. Kosters: Let me expand to that very briefly.
Dr. Kosters.
It seems to me that our problem so far this
year has not been a matter of wages rising
faster than prices or in any sense pushing
prices up.
It seems to me clearly to not have come from
the side of workers all saying to themselves,
"We can't fall behind.
We got to catch up or we got to do better."
Instead, it seems to have come on the price
side.
That is to say prices have risen a good deal
more during the course of the year than have
wages.
It seems to me very difficult to argue that
that our problem now is those costs pushing
themselves up autonomously rather than that
it's demand pushing prices up.
John: Dr. Greenspan.
Dr. Greenspan: The problem that we have got
is one which we have no firm theoretical understanding
of.
We have for the last six or seven years been
endeavoring to understand the theoretical
framework which constructs a situation in
which we have chronic inflammation in a period
of less than full utilization of resources.
It is not an explanation to say that there
are excess demands in the social system, because
that translated into the mechanisms of an
economy is a demand pull situation.
The problem that we have got is not something
we fully understand.
When we endeavor to create the relationship
of wages and prices in our econometric models,
we have found them wholly inadequate.
We have been groping for answers.
And I think at this stage, the results to
date have been most unsatisfactory.
I would not conclude from that that therefore,
we then presume that because we see a relationship
between wages and prices, which does exist,
that we can somehow create the symptoms of
the problem and presume the issue will be
resolved.
I think the experience that we have had in
endeavoring to bring down inflation by bringing
down wages or bringing down wages by bringing
down prices invariably has failed and fallen
apart.
All that we can observe is that these particular
efforts at creating the symptoms have not
worked.
And I think that to call for a particular
form of restraint, which somehow simultaneously
will bring the whole system down, I think
flies in the face of the experiences that
we and other countries have had in this whole
particular area.
There has been one of the explanations which
is this issue of inflationary expectations
as though that explains the phenomenon.
Well, it doesn't because the mere fact of
people expecting prices to rise further will
certainly induce them to take certain actions,
but it's not clear which direction.
In fact, our experience when people are concerned
about inflation is that they don't spend more.
They save more.
They can track their actions which is actually
an anti-inflationary force.
So that doesn't explain it.
I think what we have is a tremendously serious
problem.
I am very much concerned that we all grant
that there's some fundamental solutions to
this and we keep saying that we can't.
We have to create 20 million unemployed.
But that I find rather rhetorical to say the
least.
What concerns me is that we know what the
problem is.
We say it is politically, socially, and otherwise
unacceptable to do this, that, or the other
thing.
And we find that as we procrastinate, the
problem gets worse.
And the form of the socially and politically
unacceptable alternative gets worse every
year.
I submit at some point, we're gonna have to
come to grips with this problem and work very
hard to resolve it and not continuously look
for solutions for which there are no costs.
John: May I have the next question.
Sir.
Dan: Yes.
Dan [inaudible 00:53:07], Fairchild Publications.
When the President's program was first announced,
he indicated that the federal government would
use its purchasing power to encourage compliance
by not buying from contractors who violated
the guidelines.
My question is, are you moving toward asking
the nation's consumers to boycott companies
that violate the price guidelines?
Man: We haven't done so explicitly.
And I'm sorry to say that I have not yet reached
the point of being able to give you an adequate
answer.
You must recognize, however, that what we
have is a program that is in very large measure
voluntary and is indeed being enforced by
something on the order of 100 people.
And we are determined to fashion a program
which will not require any more than 100 people.
There's a tremendous amount of self-enforcement
here.
Now, in those circumstances where you're depending
very largely on volition, and you're not going
to have a field of inspectors who are going
to be able to look at prices and individual
grocery stores or the rents charged or the
prices charged for haircuts, I think that
one very important enforcement mechanism will
have to be a kind of sensitization of consumers
to this inflation and decisions by consumers
not to buy from people who are raising their
prices excessively.
John: Dr. Oswald.
Dr. Oswald.
Well, I think that's expecting something that
the guidelines don't even allow somebody to
know.
For example, on November 16th, Newsweek Magazine
raised the price of the magazine from a dollar
to a dollar and a quarter but there's no way
of an individual knowing whether that's in
compliance with the guidelines or not.
And yet that's a 25% increase in terms of
a product that is sold on the newsstands.
I think the expectation that has been given
by the President's message is that there is
a government who is concerned, has set guidelines
and will do something.
And yet you tell them on the wage side, employers
will do something, but on the price side,
nothing will be done.
Well, I think that's absurd.
I mean, we don't have any authority, any more
authority to do something about wages in a
particular locality than we have to do about
prices in that locality.
So if you're gonna talk about the limitations
of our enforcement mechanisms, those limitations
apply both to the wage and the price side.
Man: Except that on the wage side, you do
have an organized mechanism of enforcers,
employers.
There is no organized group of consumers.
Man: Oh, that's not true.
Man: I think that the presumption that employers
somehow would like to keep the wages down
no matter what, I think misses how wages are
set in a non-union area.
Wages are set not by the benevolence of the
employer but by their need to keep their good
workers in place, producing the goods that
they have to sell to their customers.
If they arbitrarily endeavored to restrain
wages below some particular market level,
they would find a substantial part of their
most productive workforce going to their competitors.
And I would think that that view that somehow
that the employers are controlling the wages
and are, in fact, the wage enforcers I think
badly miss reads how the system functions.
John: Dr. Kosters.
Dr. Kosters: I'd like to point out an oddity
about the way this kind of enforcement mechanism
works.
You have a situation where the government
is getting procurement bids and so on.
And as I understand it, instead of taking
the low bid if that firm was out of compliance
because it granted a large wage increase,
it would take the higher bid.
And it seems to me that what we don't want
to encourage is firm behavior that has high
prices and doesn't raise wages very much.
And it seems to me to be a mistake to encourage
consumers to patronize that kind of firm as
well.
John: All right.
This concludes another Public Policy Forum
presented by the American Enterprise Institute
for Public Policy Research.
This Public Policy Forum on Weapons Against
Inflation has brought you the views of four
experts in the field.
It was presented by AEI, the American Enterprise
Institute.
It is the aim of AEI to clarify issues of
the day by presenting many viewpoints in the
hope that by so doing, those who wish to learn
about the decision making process will benefit
from such a free exchange of informed and
enlightened opinion.
Man: This Public Policy Forum series is created
and supplied to this station as a public service
by the American Enterprise Institute, Washington,
DC.
For a transcript of this program, send $3.75
to the American Enterprise Institute, 1150
17th Street, Northwest, Washington, DC 20036.